jolie histoire celle d'une institutrice
qui n'avait jamais imaginé que la petite
chanson qu'elle avait écrit temps en 10
minutes en 1951 allait devenir l'une des
comptines les plus reprises par les
enfants dans toutes les écoles de france
si je vous dis pirouette cacahuète
anouchka fier leur et jacques dubourg
sans papiers sont emportés weight
cacahouète pirouette cacahuète tout le
monde connaît depuis plus de 50 ans mais
ça ne fait que quelques jours que les
habitants de ce village ont découvert
que c'est leur voisine
gabriel grandière l'auteur du tube vous
allez c'est une chanson que j'adorais
quand j'étais petit en 2008 à 92 ans
gabriel grandière est devenu une star
sans le vouloir elle ne se lasse pas de
raconter l'histoire de sa comptine
écrite en un quart d'heure en 1951 que
je juge quoi de mon bureau je file au
les amis chez denner est là et les
grands méchants vilains monte en ouganda
raccommodé avec un joli fil doré moi ce
que je cherchais d'aider des rimes en
aucun cas d'autre que ce que les gens
bougent moins de contents ils vont
tourner les bras comme champions
sa chanson est un carton composé à
alençon les enfants la chance bientôt en
bretagne à toulon et même jusqu'en
nouvelle calédonie
les vedettes de la télé s'en empare il
était un petit homme pérou est la
chanson est un immense succès ce qu'elle
lui a rapporté qu'il n'y avait pas un
centime
gabriel grandière a bien essayé de se
faire reconnaître
mais trop tard et sans preuve ça
continue est passé dans le domaine
public ce qui m'a fait plaisir c'est de
savoir qui va des générations entières d
honneur qui connaissent ça et qu'à
chaque fois que ce soit et chats et le
sourire et j'avais l'air heureux donc
j'ai fait plaisir aux gens rient ou
gauche et moi chez sa marque orange
l'ancienne institutrice a bien retenu sa
leçon aujourd'hui elle écrit toujours
des comptines mais n'oublie jamais de
déposer les droits histoire de toucher
cette fois autre chose que des
cacahuètes
[Musique]